The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your supports will
help MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view addional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: We gotta move
up to the next lowest energy
orbital, which we'll
also talk about today.
All right.
So that kind of completes
our one electron systems,
and now we're gonna talk
about multi-electrons.
But we're not going to move
far away from the topics
that we've discussed because
with multi-electrons there
are several things that are
the same and some things that
are different.
But a lot of things
are the same,
so we're going to come
back to radial probability
distributions and energy
levels and things like that.
So we'll move on
to today's handout.
So similarities and differences.
Similarities.
We have the same
shapes of orbitals,
whether we're talking about a
one electron system or more.
So again, we're gonna
have our s orbital.
So this is my version
of an s orbital
that you can hold in your hand,
where you have it spherically
symmetric and you
have probability out
in very direction of r that
you might find an electron,
except at our radial nodes.
And then we have our
p orbitals, which
can be in three different
directions, where
you have nodal planes.
So it doesn't matter what you're
talking about-- one electron
system or more--
you still are going
to have those same shapes
of the wave functions.
Other similarities again
include the nodal structure,
which I just mentioned.
Whether s is always going to
be spherically symmetrical.
p is gonna have
those nodal planes.
The angular nodal planes.
So that's the same.
Differences, though, have to
do with the energy levels.
So orbitals in a
multi-electron atoms
are lower-- more
negative-- in energy
than their corresponding
orbitals in the H atom.
So let's take a look at this and
think about why this is true.
So here we have our
friend the hydrogen atom.
It has a small Z. Z equals 1.
Doesn't get smaller than that.
We have our 1s.
Then we have our n equals 2.
And we talked about the
fact that in a 1 electron
system like hydrogen--
these are all
degenerate in energy with
respect to each other,
so they're all equal in energy.
And then we have our n equals 3.
Again, degenerate energy
levels and n equals 4 up here.
But when you go to a
multi-electron system,
the first thing
that I'll point out
is that the energy
level is lower.
So we have 1s over here.
Now 1s is a more
negative lower number.
And we can think about this in
multi-electron systems-- you
have a bigger Z. So you
have more positive charge
and it's kind of hauling all
of those energy levels closer.
So it's a lower energy
for all of those.
So 1s, again, lower,
and we have 2s.
Again, that's lower in energy.
And now importantly,
2s and 2p are no longer
degenerate with respect
to each other in energy.
So now the 2p system is
higher in energy than the 1s
and so on.
So we have 3s down
here and then the 3p's.
So compared to hydrogen
in a multi-electron atom,
n is not the sole determinate
of what the energy levels are.
Now, instead of just
n we have n and l.
So let's review.
This is good.
This is all getting
ready for the test.
Some equations that
you've seen before.
And again, equations will
be on the equations sheet.
You don't have to memorize them.
And the equation
sheet for the exam
is handed out today, so
you can take a look a it
and see where things are.
If I forgot anything
you can ask me questions
and maybe we'll add some
more if I forgot any ones.
So for a one electron
system, binding energy
equals minus the ionization
energy equals minus Z squared
RH, the Rydberg
constant, over N squared.
And so for hydrogens Z is 1,
but there are other 1 electron
at least ions and then
you have to worry about Z.
What about a
multi-electron system?
Looks pretty much the same, but
now instead of just having n we
have n and l because l matters
with a multi-electron system.
So the binding energy
for the electron
is minus the ionization
energy-- that's always
going to [INAUDIBLE] true.
The binding energy
is always going
to be equal to minus the
ionization energy, which
is equal to minus
Z. But now we have
a different Z. We
have Z effective,
which is abbreviated Z eff.
So this is the effective
charge, not the actual charge.
And that's squared.
And then we have Rydberg
constant and n again.
So Z effective is
not the same as Z,
and it's not the same
Z because of shielding.
So we talked about
shielding a little bit,
and I made this
point that you need
to think about shielding
a little differently.
It's not just about the
average size of the orbital.
It's more about the
likelihood-- the probability--
that they're going
to be electrons close
to the nucleus that will
participate in-- that
will be affected by shielding.
So let's look at
some extreme cases
now and think about
what's happening
in terms of this shielding.
So extreme case one.
Extreme shielding.
Maximum shielding.
So we have the case.
We have the helium nucleus.
We have moved far in
the periodic table.
We've left hydrogen. And
so what is the charge going
to be on helium nucleus?
Plus 2.
So now we have
this electron one.
We're interested in how
much this electron is
shielded by electron two
because we've got two electrons.
Now say electron two
is close to the nucleus
and it's maximally
shielding electron one
from this positive
charge down here.
So think about this electron.
I like to think about
this electron two
as kind of the
elasti-girl of electrons.
So elasti-girl electron
is shielding everywhere,
stretching everywhere
around that nucleus.
Just completely shielding
it from electron
one, using the full negative
charge to really shield.
So in that kind of exaggerated
case, the Z effective is not 2.
It's 1.
So this electron
basically cancels
the whole positive
charge of this nucleus.
Really shields that away.
And so this is the effective
charge with total shielding.
Maximal shielding
that you can get.
So now we can calculate what
the binding energy-- or if we
wanted, what the
ionization energy would
be for this case, given that
particular effective charge.
So again, the binding
energy of electron one
is equal to minus its ionization
energy equal to minus the Z
effective squared
R H over n squared.
And we can plug
in those numbers.
Don't forget the minus.
We can have Z effective 1 over
1 and we calculate this value,
which is, of course,
just the Rydberg constant
or minus the Rydberg
constant minus 2.18 times 10
to the minus 18th joules.
So this is just like
it was a hydrogen atom.
A one electron system.
So it had two electrons but
one of the electron shielded
so completely it was like
a one electron system.
Again, this is an exaggerated
case of total shielding.
So now let's go to
the other extreme
and consider zero shielding.
No shielding at all.
So here we have
the helium nucleus.
We have electron
one is now close
and electron two
is pretty far away.
So again, we're asking, how
much is this electron one going
to shielded by electron two?
And in this extreme
scenario, electron two
is not participating
in shielding at all.
It's far away.
I'm not sure what it's doing.
Maybe it lost its super
suit and can't find it.
It might be at
the dry cleaner's.
We don't know what's going on.
In any case, it is
out of the game.
It is not involved.
It is not shielding at all.
So in this extreme
case, electron one
feels that full
force of the nucleus.
So its effective charge is
the full complete plus 2.
So we can plug that
in now and calculate
what the binding
energy is going to be.
Again, binding energy
for electron one
equals minus the ionization
energy for this electron.
Same equation.
We put this in but now
the Z effective is 2
and we can calculate that.
And now we get a value
of minus 8.72 times 10
to the minus 18th joules.
And this is actually
the same as you
would get for the scenario
of helium plus, which
is a one electron system.
Then, in a one
electron system you
can use a formula of
just Z where Z is 2
and get your value.
So here are the two
extreme cases for helium.
One it's like a hydrogen atom
one electron system, and one
it's like helium plus.
And one case is like it
just has one electron,
and in the other case
you have zero shielding.
So extreme case one
the Z effective is 1,
and we have the
binding energy that's
very similar to hydrogen. And so
this is a total shielding case.
It's shields so much it's
like a one electron case.
Extreme case two you
have the full force.
So there's zero shielding.
No shielding at all.
And then, this is
like helium plus case
where you've actually
lost that other electron.
It's not shielding.
It's not even there.
So no shielding.
And the reality in most cases
is that you're in between,
and you can determine
this experimentally.
You can measure
ionization energies.
So if we measured the
ionization energy for helium
we would find that it's 3.94
times 10 to the minus 18th.
So it's greater than the
2.18 and less than the 8.72.
So it's in between, and that's
what you find most of the time.
The Z effective is in
between zero shielding
and total shielding.
So we can calculate what
the Z effective is actually
in this case if we know
the ionization energy.
So if you know the
ionization energy
you can calculate
the Z effective,
or if you're given
a Z effective you
can calculate what
the ionization
energy should be for that case.
And so I told you that it
was measured at 3.94 times 10
to the minus 18th.
And so in that case
the Z effective,
if you plug the numbers
in would be 1.34.
And so this number is in fact
in between the two cases.
With total shielding you
would have a Z effective of 1
and with no shielding you
have a Z effective of 2.
And so in reality,
we're somewhere
in between in this case.
So thinking about this
now, let's try your hand
at a clicker question and
see if you can tell me
which of these is a possible
Z effective for an element
with a Z equals 3.
I'm doing good time wise.
OK.
10 more seconds.
So does someone want to say why
the other ones are not correct?
Why don't you run up there and
you can give them this pen?
American Chemical Society pen.
Hand up there.
AUDIENCE: Who had their hand up?
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
I think it's on.
AUDIENCE: So in the
case of no shielding
the charge should be 3, and in
the case of maximum shielding
there's only two electrons
in the 1s so it would be 1.
So anything below 1 would
be beyond maximum shielding,
so it's gotta be
between 1 and 3.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
Yeah, that's right.
So now we're going
to talk more about
why shielding is important.
And shielding really has
to do with this order
of orbital energy that we all
know and are very fond of.
So when I show you this we
want to ask the question,
why is 2s lower than
2p or 3s lower than 3p?
So let's take a look
at this, and we're
going to go back to our radial
probability distribution.
I told you I wasn't going
to leave it for very long
and we're back again.
So here, again, if we're
considering 2s and 2p--
so we'll consider
this case here--
the maximum probable
radius is longer.
It's greater for 2s than for 2p.
But what we really
care about when
we're talking about shielding
is this part right here.
And so there are different
ways you can express this.
You can say that the electrons
in the orbital with lower
values of l, like 2s
is lower than 2p--
those electrons penetrate
closer to the nucleus,
even though we have this trend
where the radius decreases
with increasing l.
So despite this size
difference, when
you compare this dotted
line with this line here,
there's more
probability that they're
going to be electrons
near the nucleus with 2s.
And that results in
this lower energy.
So there's less shielding
for the s orbitals
than for the p orbitals.
And as a result of that,
with less shielding
because their probability
is that they're closer,
that they're bound more tightly,
you have this lower energy.
So that explains this
energy difference.
So we can look at this
now for the three system
again for n equals 3.
And here we see that p
electrons are also less shielded
than the d electrons,
despite the fact if you look
that the most probable radius
over here is longer for p
than for d.
But now, if we look near the
nucleus at the probability
that they're going to be
electrons near the nucleus,
there's a higher
probability that they'll
be electrons near the
nucleus with p than with d.
So these are going to be less
shielded and lower in energy.
And if I throw s
on there now we see
s has the most probability
here of being closer.
Then p then d.
So for a multi-electron
atom, the order of energy--
we have s lower than p, p lower
than d, d lower than f due
to this shielding.
So again, we want
to be able to draw
some version of these diagrams
with appropriate features
to explain answers.
And this all leads
into what we're
doing next, which is
electron configurations.
So we're going to
think about how
we're going to write the
electron configurations
and this indicates how
you build up in energy.
So electron configurations.
So first, we're going to fill
our electrons in to the energy
states that are our lowest.
Nature doesn't want
to do a lot of work,
so it's going to put
them in the lower states.
And again, where those
energy levels are
depends on, for multi-electron
atoms, both n and l
And we're going to put them
in one electron at a time,
starting with the
lowest energy state
and heading the following rules.
So there are some rules in
doing this, and most of you
have probably heard
some of these before.
And if you haven't I'm
sure you'll like them.
I know you heard this because
I already just told you
about that a few minutes ago.
We have Pauli's
Exclusion Principle,
which says that you can't have
the same four quantum numbers.
So if you put one electron in
and it's spin up the next one
has to be spin down.
And Hund's Rule, which is one of
my favorite rules in chemistry,
and that is when you're adding
electrons to the same state
you're going to put them
in singly, when there's
degenerate energy orbitals,
before a second one enters
the same orbital.
And the spins remain parallel
as you're adding them across.
So let's consider these and
put some electrons into these.
And we'll do this for oxygen,
which is a Z equals 8 system.
So first, I want to put them
in the lowest energy state.
So that's 1s.
So I'll put one
electron in there.
And then I'm going to put
the second electron in there
because it's the
lowest energy state,
so I'm going to fill it up.
But I'm going to pay attention
to Pauli's Exclusion Principle
and put it in spin down.
One electron spin up.
One electron spin down.
I can't put them both
spin up because they would
have the same four
quantum numbers,
and that would violate
Pauli's Exclusion Principle.
So next I'm going to put
electrons in 2s because that's
the next lowest energy state.
I'll put one in spin up.
And then, because of Pauli, I'll
put the other one in spin down.
Next, we come to the 2p system.
And I'm going to put
the first electron in,
but I'm not going to
pair the second one.
I'm going to put electron
in the second orbital, both
being spin up.
And then I'm going
to do that again.
Most people kind of
refer to the Hund's Rule
as kind of the rule
of seating on a bus,
where it always seems
that one person goes in--
and even though there are two
seats, one person takes it.
The next person gets on the bus.
Doesn't sit next to the
person who's already there.
They take another empty
seat and so on and so on.
And so you fill up the bus
with one person per bench
before all those
seats are taken.
Then the next person comes on.
Sadly has to sit
with someone else.
So if you think about that,
that's the Hund's Rule.
You'll always
remember to do that.
And once you put one in each,
then the next person on the bus
has to sit next to
someone and they're
going to do that spin down.
Because if it was
spin up again you'd
have the same four
quantum numbers.
So these are the rules that you
need to know to put these in.
And then, after you do that
you can write an electron
configuration that
says what you did.
So here we can
write it this way.
We'll say we have 1s two.
There are two
electrons in the 1s.
2s two.
Two electrons in 2s.
And 2p four.
We have four electrons
in the 2p orbitals.
And if for some
reason the question
asks you to specify m sub
l, you can do that too.
So then instead of just saying
2p4 then you would say 2px2.
So there were two
electrons in px.
And then to 2pz1 and 2py1.
And if you don't
write 1, 1 is implied.
So you will see this both ways.
You will see the 1
indicated and then
you'll see the orbital
just listed with nothing.
If you do that you are implying
there is one electron in there.
If you don't mean to imply
there is one electron in there
don't write it that
way because that's
what is implied if
that's the way it is.
So now let's do a
clicker question.
OK.
10 more seconds.
I think we can get at
least 93% on this one.
That's not bad.
90.
That was a decent guess.
So I think the trick
here was just counting.
So the bottom one
that some people
liked-- there are only six
electrons and that has more.
AUDIENCE: Question.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Are the p and
sub l notations always
filled in with order
x, z, y or can it
be x, y, z, or [INAUDIBLE]?
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Yeah, you
don't have to worry about that.
That's kind of arbitrary
what you put for that.
So if it is indicated
then that's fine,
but we didn't give you an
option that would be different.
So now you can imagine that if
you were writing these electron
configurations and you were
asked to write an electron
configuration for something
way down on the periodic table
you would be writing for a
very, very, very long time.
So you can use information
about core electrons and valence
electrons to make
your life easier.
Now, sometimes you will be
asked to write the full electron
configuration.
It will say don't
use the noble gas
short hand, then that's
what you have to do.
Very important on the exam.
Read questions carefully.
So let's introduce this concept
of core electrons and valence
electrons.
So if we look at the periodic
table we have our 1s1, 1s2,
and then we come down.
We have our 2s's and our 2p's,
and then we have a noble gas,
and then we come down and
we have our first 3s1.
And so if we're
talking about sodium,
we have core
electrons, which are
the electrons that make up
the noble gas element that's
on the row before.
And then, those are
usually not very reactive.
They're held pretty tight.
And the valence electrons--
the valence electrons
are the electrons that do all
the exciting chemistry-- lose
and gain valence electrons.
They're the fun ones.
And so those are going to
be beyond that noble gas
configuration.
Those core electrons.
And so here sodium has one 3s1.
So we can also write sodium
then as bracket neon,
indicating the noble
gas before, and then
just put the valence electrons.
The 3s1.
And unless it's
clearly specified
you're not supposed to do
that this will be acceptable.
So we can go on in that
row of the periodic table
in the third period.
And so the next one
we would have 3s2,
and then we jump over
here to the 3p's and so
on and so on until we get
to our next noble gas.
So this is pretty
straightforward.
There are no exceptions
on the third period.
But when we get to the fourth
period of the periodic table
we start to have a
couple of exceptions
that you will be
responsible for.
So it's looking good up
here in the beginning.
We have now our noble
gas, and then we
have our valence
electrons 4s1, 4s2,
and then we start down
in the 3d's over here.
And when we get halfway
through we have an exception.
So you have exceptions
halfway through and also
when you're almost at the end.
So instead of having
4s2 3d4, it really
wants to have 5 electrons.
And in this case, instead
of 4s2 3d9 it wants 10.
So it like things being
half full or totally full,
and so you have these
exceptions there.
So you don't have a d4
and you don't have d9.
And you're responsible
for these two,
and then in the period
right below same position
same exception.
So you can think
about this-- I don't
know if it's four exceptions or
really just two in two places,
but these are the
exceptions you need to know.
So in the fifth it's the ones
right below are the same.
You're not going to
have d4 or a d9 here.
So you bump one up
because it's just happier
when it has 5 or 10
electrons in the d orbitals.
You're also responsible
for knowing the orders.
We have a question way up there.
Who wants to run?
Get some exercise.
I don't always see questions
so yell out my name
if I don't see people.
I am wearing my glasses.
That's good.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So what happens
when we have an ion?
Like a titanium [INAUDIBLE]--
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
Good question.
I'm getting to that.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Cool.
Thanks.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
Hold on a minute.
Yes.
We're getting to ions.
They're right at the end.
So first, let's
consider what happens
when we're not doing an ion.
And there are a couple different
ways that we can look at this.
This is one way to remember.
So you just write out 1s,
2s, 2p, threes, your fours,
your fives, your six, your
sevens, and then draw a line.
First you fill 1s, then 2s,
2p, 3s, 3p, 4s, 3d, 4p, 5s, et
cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
That works.
That's one way to do it.
It's kind of time consuming.
Not sure that's the easiest way.
The other way that
you can do-- this
is the periodic table you'll
be getting on the exam,
and you can just
remember what's happening
at these different cases.
So over here we're
filling up our s's.
Over here we're filling up
our p's, except for helium.
Over here we're doing our
d's in the transition metals.
Over here we have f.
And then in terms of
the period numbers-- so
we have one over here.
So we do 1s2, 2s2,
or 1s1, 1s3, 2s.
Then we come over here.
We have the two p's, three
s's, three p's, four s's.
Then we have four d's and go to
four p's, five s's, four d's,
five p's, and then we
can't forget when we
get down here that we have f.
What number goes here?
Four.
So when you get to
principal quantum
number four is when you
start having f orbitals.
So if you just
remember this, it's
going to help you
think about what
the energy levels-- how
you're going to write those
configurations.
So maybe I'll leave this up and
we'll do a clicker question now
on this.
And you have your periodic
table available to look at.
And then we'll get to ions.
This should be 93%.
Yeah.
OK.
10 seconds.
Well, 85.
That's still pretty good.
So this one was one of
our exceptions over here.
And we wanted to have no d9.
So it just is happier
as d10 system,
so that's our exception.
One of the four that you
need to know for this.
So now we have our two
methods of remembering this.
And we did the clicker
question, and so I'm
going to jump to ions.
There's one question
on problem sets
and people have been
asking about ions.
So when we're just here
filling up our 4s ones.
4s we're putting
in first and then
we're going to our 3d, which
is what we just learned about.
But what actually happens when
you start putting electrons
in your d orbitals is
that the orbital energy
of the d orbitals
drops below the 4s.
So once they start
becoming filled you
have this change that happens.
And this is really
only important
when you're talking about ions.
So if we were asking
here about this one--
so we would normally say,
OK, we put our two 4s in
and then we have
two 3d electrons.
But now, because we've
started to fill the 3d,
if we're going to really do
this in terms of energy level
we could reverse the order.
And we would accept both of
these for the neutral ion.
You could do either here.
But importantly, if you
start ionizing it and losing
electrons, you need
to think where are
those electrons coming from?
Which are the electrons
that are easiest to remove?
And what happens is that you
end up losing the 4s2 electrons.
And so the configuration for
titanium plus 2 is just 3d2.
And so this is different.
Ions behave
differently, and now you
can go run and finish
problem set two.
That last question.
And this is because now we're
at the end of exam one material.
So one thing I didn't get
to-- it said in the beginning.
Number 12 on the problem
set we're not going
to get to until next week.
So if you've done number 12
already you can turn it in.
It won't be graded and you can
turn it in again on problem set
3 so you won't have wasted time.
But that won't be on
exam one material.
So this is the end
of exam one material.
And read your instructions
for the exams very carefully.
And there's a couple
questions, but I think
it's too noisy to answer them.
Note that not everyone is
taking the exam in this room,
and you need to go to
the appropriate place.
So please look at
the instructions.
All right.
And who won the clicker
competition for today?
Recitation 12.